[Musique]
surveillance renforcée pour 20
départements susceptibles d'être confiné
localement dès le week-end du 6 mars les
zones où la situation épidémique se
dégrade en ile-de-france notamment la
mairie de paris émet l'hypothèse
confinement de trois semaines avec la
perspective à l'issue d'un retour à la
vie normale
une proposition qualifiée de fadaises
par jean castex
[Musique]
suite et fin du sommet européen virtuel
consacré en grande partie à la pandémie
au menu des discussions aujourd'hui la
campagne de vaccination éval matheron a
tenté de convaincre ses homologues de
l'union européenne d' appuyer sa
proposition d'envoyer 13 millions de
doses antico vite gratuite aux soignants
africain hier les 27 états membres ont
appelé à maintenir des restrictions
fermé à accélérer la production de
vaccins pour faire face aux variants du
coronavirus bombardements en syrie joe
biden riposte aux récentes attaques
contre la présence américaine en irak
première opération militaire du nouveau
locataire de la maison blanche les
etats-unis ont frappé hier des
infrastructures utilisées par des
milices pro iranienne selon washington
une attaque qualifiée de défensive par
le ministère de la défense damas dénonce
de son côté une agression
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france pour
cette nouvelle des meilleurs
d'information depuis deux heures
maintenant une partie des
alpes-maritimes et l'agglomération de
dunkerque sont officiellement sous
cloche jusqu'à lundi 6h nouvelles
mesures appliquées pour tenter
d'améliorer la situation sanitaire qui
s'est fortement dégradée ces derniers
temps des restrictions qui pourrait
s'étendre à 20 départements dès le 6
mars prochain annonce du premier
ministre hier les bouches-du-rhône
l'oise le nord la somme la drôme l'île
de france ou encore la moselle
elles sont concernées des concertations
sont prévues avec les élus locaux
objectif retarder si l'option
confinement nationale la mairie de paris
évoqué hier un confinement de trois
semaines avec à là clé l'espoir de
tourouvre y compris baa restaurants et
lieux culturels
il détend père est aujourd'hui le
premier adjoint qui avaient affirmé
préférer un confinement tout court
plutôt qu'un confirmant uniquement le
week end mettre paris à sous cloche une
idée vivement taclé par le premier
ministre jean castex une déclaration en
marge d'un déplacement au centre
hospitalier de nantes
vous avez entendu la mairie de paris
dira qu'il faut qu on confine trois
semaines et puis c'est fini
mais vous savez très bien qu'avec les
variants et cetera
ce n'est pas possible il ne faut jamais
raconter des fadaises
les parisiens principaux concernés par
ces éventuelles mesures sont plutôt
mitigées à l'idée d'un reconfirmant
partiel au total écouter leurs actions
et seul mesures à prendre c'est de
vacciner la population en entier
tout simplement donc c'est sert à rien
parce que de toute façon ce sera
exactement la même chose on va nous
bloquer et ils savent abc on va
reprendre vie et puis ça va recommencer
encore il y en a marre ça fait un an
très dur je pense que le week end les
gens sortent beaucoup les fêtes les
soirées voilà même si on dit pas c'est
vrai qu'on y va quand même
mais du coup il faudrait il faudrait
arrêter ça très très compliqué à
organiser
je pense ça va faire plus de mal que de
bien après encore une fois s'il arrive à
nous démontrer l'efficacité de ce qu'il
propose
nous sommes enfin je pense que nous
serons prêts à les suivre
moralement ça va être compliqué pour les
français d'accepter un confinement
surtout le week-end parce qu'il nous
reste tellement peu de liberté que
c'étaient les seuls qui nous faisait
plaisir un truc mais après je pense que
je fais confiance dans les hôpitaux et
dans le gouvernement s'il estime qu'il
faut passer à un confinement va il sera
obligé de le faire et puis voilà on
essaie d'y croire
accélérer les campagnes de vaccination
pour faire face aux variants du couronne
un virus c'est l'appel des 27 états
membres
hier au premier jour du sommet européen
objectif affiché faire front commun dans
la lutte contre l'épidémie maxima moulin
face aux politiques nationales l'union
européenne réaffirme sa position
les dirigeants européens ont rappelé à
l'issue d'un sommet tenu en
visioconférence leur projet d'avancer
ensemble
l'objectif contre une nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 avec une politique
commune
près d'un an après les premiers
confinement lui le sait qu'elle doit
faire face à une crise sanitaire mais
aussi sociale les citoyens sont de plus
en plus fatigués du coc vide et l'année
a été très éprouvante mais nous ne
devons pas relâcher nos efforts
maintenant notre honda stations non
seulement la situation reste grave dans
de nombreuses régions d'europe mais nous
devons aussi faire attention aux
variants qui se répandent
il ya donc beaucoup de défis à relever
devant nous jardin face ce jeudi l'union
européenne a rappelé que les efforts de
ses pays membres doivent être uniforme
dans la stratégie de vaccination un plan
pour faire face à la montée en puissance
des variants notamment britanniques
confiante quant à la distribution des
prochaines doses par les laboratoires
lieu veut vacciner une grande partie de
la population nous sommes convaincus que
nous sommes capables d'atteindre notre
objectif qu'à la fin de l'été nous
aurons vacciner 70 % de la population
adulte vaccination à me dire ce sont 255
millions de personnes dans l'union
européenne et si nous regardons nos
prévisions c'est un objectif que nous
nous savons capables d'atteindre outre
les vaccins
l'union européenne veut également
simplifier les déplacements à
l'intérieur de son territoire mais doit
faire face aux mesures locale de chaque
pays qui tentent d'endiguer l'épidémie
avec une fermeture de ses frontières
une épine dans le pied pour les
dirigeants européens qui prônent une
circulation plus fluide
on est comme souvent
concernant les voyages nous devons
respecter la proches communes dont nous
avons convenu les déplacements non
essentiels peuvent toujours être soumis
à des restrictions
mais les mesures doivent être
proportionnées et nous devons assurer la
circulation des biens et des services
dans le marché unique en utilisant les
voies de circulation dite verte
je fais confiance à la commission pour
veiller à ce que ces principes soient
respectés respecte les avis des
dirigeants européens divergent cependant
à propos d'un possible passeport
vaccinale et des pays dont le tourisme
est primordial pour leurs économies
comme chypre où la grèce veulent une
adoption rapide de ce passeport une
possibilité aussitôt réfutée par berlin
et paris qui juge une inégalité de
traitement
emmanuel macron prenant pas sanitaire
basé sur des tests négatifs récent
attire tout de suite l'attention sur le
fait que quand je dis pas sanitaire
c'est que ça ne peut pas être soumis au
vaccin
parce que si on arrive à un moment dans
le printemps à rouvrir certains de ces
lieux
nous ne saurions conditionné leur accès
à une vaccination alors même que nous
n'aurions même pas ouvert la vaccination
aux plus jeunes d'entre nous ferait
invraisemblable les vingt-sept ont
finalement confié à la commission
européenne la tâche d'élaborer les
conditions d'un certificat vaccinale
avec pour objectif de synchroniser les
systèmes de santé et les structures
douanières de chaque pays
mais angela merkel l'a assuré le
passeport vaccinale ne signifiera pas
que ses détenteurs seront les seuls à
pouvoir voyager
autre sujet abordé aujourd'hui la
question du renforcement de l'autonomie
de l'union européenne pour assurer sa
sécurité une visioconférence avec le
secrétaire général de l'otan rienne
stoltenberg a été organisée ce matin le
tout dans un contexte d'affaiblissement
de l'alliance atlantique et de
désengagement américain
elle patron de l'otan et le président du
conseil européen ont exprimé leur
confiance en la nouvelle administration
à baden pour renforcer la sécurité du
territoire
l'otan a joui il joue toujours un rôle
clé pour relier l'amérique du nord et
l'europe
nous partageons les mêmes valeurs
démocratiques nous avons des intérêts
stratégiques
main et je suis totalement convaincu que
cette nouvelle administration byden
offre une occasion unique de renouveler
cette alliance transatlantique entre
l'europe et les états unis
les menaces auxquelles nous étions
confrontés avant la pandémie sont
toujours là les actions agressives de la
russie des formes plus brutale de
terrorisme les cyberattaques sophistiqué
la montée de la chine et toutes les
implications du changement climatique
sur la sécurité
aucun pays aucun continent ne peut donc
faire face seule à ces défis pas
l'europe seule pas l'amérique du nord
seule mais l'europe et l'amérique du
nord ensemble en belgique des masques
distribués par le gouvernement hôte
était heureux été retiré car
possiblement toxiques la présence de
nanoparticules d'argent et de dioxyde de
titane a été détecté des substances qui
pourrait être cancérigène à l'inhalation
les autorités sanitaires belges
recommande donc de ne plus utiliser les
15 millions de masques de protection en
tissu fourni au printemps 2001 lors de
la première vague en recommandations qui
se tiendra jusqu'à communication des
résultats d'une enquête complémentaire
sur l'heure est aux xi cité potentiel en
juin dernier le ministère belge de la
santé avait pourtant estimé que les
masques ne représentait pas de danger
écouter à présent l'analyse de laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgien il
était avec nous pour en parler j'ai déjà
eu recours à ces masques et je n'ai pour
ma santé personnelle absolument aucune
inquiétude par rapport à l'utilisation
de ces masques qu'il faut bien
évidemment retenir et puisque nous avons
un léger doute
on est dans une phase où par prudence on
prend des précautions exagérées et on
crée d'ailleurs des inquiétudes chez les
gens parce que cette affaire de masque
on aurait mieux fait de ne pas en parler
les quantités de métaux sont vraiment
infinitésimale et ne présentent pas de
risque pour la santé de mon point de vue
en tant que citoyen et en tant que
médecin dans la phase de psychose
sanitaire nous sommes en ce moment ce
n'est peut-être pas la peine d'en
rajouter de compte tenu du retard du
programme vaccinal européen les
européens en général et les belges en
particulier vont devoir subir
des mois et des mois de couvre-feu et de
confinement encore donc nous rajoutons
pas des des source d'angoissés et de
dépression sont les pays bas ou la cour
d'appel de la haye donne finalement
raison au gouvernement pour
l'instauration du couvre-feu
la pandémie est une raison suffisante
selon leurs termes pour imposer cette
restriction à la population le 16
février un tribunal de première instance
avait déclaré la mesure illégale en
raison de la violation du droit à la
liberté de mouvement et de la vie privée
une décision qui avait contraint les
autorités à créer une nouvelle loi en
urgence pour contourner ce jugement
victoire aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement de mark rutte qui vient de
prolonger les restrictions elles
jusqu'au 15 mars
vous aviez fallières anesthésiste à
l'hôpital de drake près de rotterdam
était avec nous il s'est voulu rassurant
sur la situation au pays bas qui selon
lui est moins dramatique qu'elle n'a été
présentée je pense qu'à l'origine
personne n'aurait été vraiment contre et
il y a eu un espèce de commenter en
direct de bourrage de crâne que depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale n'a été
jamais arrivé en fait dans la réalité
votre monde presque tout le monde s'y
plient rentrer à 9 heures c'est pas très
très tôt et on voit les chiffres
bon là on a une dégradation un peu
déchiré c'est assez limité si je compare
à la france autant on a eu on a 23 % sur
les quinze derniers jours d'augmentation
du nombre de cas positifs un seder ça ne
veut rien dire quand on ne prend pas en
compte le nombre d'hospitalisations la
mortalité et les chiffres en réa et ceux
ci sont très stables ou un peu à la
baisse
on travaille toujours en flux tendu mais
on arrive toujours maintenant rattraper
toutes les listes d'attentes de soins
réguliers
donc même si c'est beaucoup de travail
c'est stable l'autriche se dit prête à
discuter avec moscou de la livraison
d'une possible production du vaccin
russes sur son territoire
le président russe vladimir poutine et
le chancelier autrichien sebastian
courson
venus de pourparlers lors d'un appel
téléphonique ce vendredi l'initiative de
vienne
le spoutnik v séduit plusieurs états de
l'union européenne l'allemagne et
l'espagne se disent intéressés par le
vaccin russe s'ils obtenaient
l'approbation des organismes de
règlementation européen est là en grès
de son côté elle l'a déjà enregistré sur
son territoire l'autriche pourrait donc
rejoindre la liste les problématiques de
la lutte contre la propagation de
l'épidémie de coronavirus ont été
discuté en détail y compris la
possibilité de fournir le vaccin russe
sportives et à l'autriche ainsi que
d'établir sa production conjointe au
venezuela à la pandémie s'ajoute aux
sanctions économiques imposées aux
gouvernements de nicolás maduro offre au
détriment de la population est difficile
notamment de sa privée de
s'approvisionner en produits de base
alors les vénézuéliens s'organise et des
petits commerces émergent dans les
quartiers pauvres de caracas la capitale
le récit de francs soit 6 km h
au pied de cet immeuble d'un quartier
populaire de caracas
ce petit magasin est une véritable oasis
beurre huile café champeau dentifrice
des produits de base mais difficilement
accessible le venezuela est toujours
confiné les magasins non essentiels
fermé et un seulement par famille est
autorisé à sortir de son domicile pour
se rendre au supermarché ou dans les
pharmacies
ici comme le commerce est à l'intérieur
du quartier les gens plus de facilités
pour sortir au moment où ils peuvent
acheter leurs produits et bien sûr les
prix sont bas parce qu'on essaie en
vivant ici de trouver les meilleurs prix
afin d'aider la communauté la
distribution mensuelle de produits
alimentaires introduite en 2016 par le
président maduro pour faire face aux
pénuries a été mise à mal par les effets
conjugués de la pandémie et des
sanctions internationales
au total ce sont plus de 6 millions de
vénézuéliens qui en bénéficient avec le
blocus la pandémie vous n'obtenez pas
les produits la plupart des produits
distribués par le gouvernement ont été
importés le peuple s'est donc organisé
en créant ses boutiques ses kiosques sur
un pâté de maison là où il y avait un
magasin il y en a maintenant 5 5 petites
boutiques avec toutes sortes de produits
il y a deux semaines à l'issue d'une
visite d'une dizaine de jours au
venezuela
l'envoyé de l'onu a déclaré dans son
rapport préliminaire que les sanctions
des états unis et de l'union européenne
contre le pays aggravé la crise
humanitaire à l'ena douanes demande à
washington la levée des mesures
coercitives unilatérales aux effets
dévastateurs sur la santé l'éducation et
l'alimentation de la population que des
éoliennes
damas dénonce une agression lendemain de
la première intervention militaire de
l'administration byden le président
américain a lancé ce jeudi en syrie
n'offense yves contre des
infrastructures prétendument utilisé par
des milices pro iranienne un premier
fait d'armes en réponse aux récentes
attaques en irak contre le personnel des
états unis et de la coalition menée par
washington des frappes qui ont fait
réagir la russie on voit ça avec notre
correspondante à moscou prague hoffman
la diplomatie russe a condamné les
frappes américaines en syrie
la porte parole du ministère russe des
affaires étrangères malien sera l'avant
a appelé à respecter l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de la
république arabe syrienne je vous
propose d'écouter
nous condamnons fermement les actions de
ce genre
nous appelons à un respect
inconditionnel de la souveraineté et de
l'intégrité territoriale de la syrie
nous réaffirmons notre rejet de toute
tentative de faire du territoire syrien
une arène pour des règlements de comptes
politiques
en outre le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov a dévoilé des détails de
l'opération américaine en série le
ministre russe a également déclaré que
selon les dernières informations que
possèdent la partie russe mais qui reste
encore à confirmer
le but ultime des états unis et de faire
éclater la série écoutez le nôtre nos
militaires ont été prévenus quatre ou
cinq minutes avant les frappes bien sûr
même si on parle comme il est de règle
de la désescalade du conflit dans les
relations entre les militaires russes et
américains des notifications de ce type
quand la frappe est sur le point d'être
lancés ne donne rien ces derniers temps
on entend diverses informations en
provenance de diverses sources
à l'heure actuelle nous ne pouvons pas
les confirmer nous souhaitons interroger
les américains directement selon
lesquelles il aurait pris la décision de
ne jamais se retirer de la syrie
tant que ce pays ne se sera pas effondré
je rappelle qu'il s'agit des frappes
aériennes que les états unis ont
effectué le 25 février
en ciblant des infrastructures qui
serait utilisé par des milices pro
iranienne dans le nord-est de la série
il s'agit de la première opération
militaire sur l'administration de joe
biden est coté à présent l'analyse de
gérard vespière directeur de recherche à
la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient par la géopolitique comme
une affaire de personnes à la
géopolitique est une structure à une
intervention à autour d'intérêts autour
de lignes de défense et a donc c'est
dans ce cette vision là qu'il faut
comprendre et interpréter les actes la
continuité des actions américaines dans
le temps sur cette région qu une
politique étrangère et quel que soit
l'état s'instruit et s'inclut dans le
temps donc al'avantage la différence
entre la nouvelle administration
américaine et l'ancien c'est sa clarté
ah je pense que l'administration
précédente n'était pas forcément clair
il pouvait y avoir un double discours
dans le cas de l'administration actuelle
sa disco très clair et avec une
détermination dont on vient de voir
effectivement actions et résultats
l'arménie au bord de la fracture les
deux camps restent mobilisés d'un côté
les partisans de nikol pashinian le
premier ministre qu'ils accusent l état
major des armées d'avoir tenté un coup
d'état hier de l'autre l'opposition qui
demandent sa démission
les protestataires ont passé la nuit
devant le parlement
ils étaient toujours rassemblés à ce
matin nipple pashinian est contesté
depuis la défaite militaire face à
l'azerbaïdjan dans le haut karabagh est
les tensions se sont exacerbées hier et
ce matin le ministre français des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
appelé au dialogue pour sortir de cette
crise politique
la france souhaite que le dialogue
puisse s'instaurer dans ce pays en
s'appuyant sur la légitimité du
président arménien sarkissian et du
premier ministre
les éléments de la démocratie
arméniennes doivent tenir le coup nous
sommes très attachés à la démocratie
arménienne à la stabilité de ce pays qui
a des ressorts démocratique profond pour
en parler avec nous au françois
costantini géopolitologue françois
costantini bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une défaite
vécue comme une humiliation nationale
par certains l'accord conclu par
l'arménie sous l'égide de moscou lui est
il réellement défavorable bonsoir oui
cet accord est intervenu en quelque
sorte
or au moment où l'arménie était au bord
du précipice
alors l'accord en quelque sorte sauvé
l'arménie et sauver le lot grab bag mais
à quel prix c'est à dire que d'une part
l'arménie a perdu tout bénéfice des
conquêtes de 1992 1994 sur le
l'azerbaïdjan elle opte aujourd'hui
qu'un corridor qui est contrôlé par par
la russie et elle a perdu pratiquement
25 30 30% du territoire du du haut
karabakh
donc c'est un accord en effet qui marque
un recul pour la première fois de
l'arménie depuis l'accession à
l'indépendance il ya 30 ans l'armée à se
joindre désormais à l'opposition pour
demander la démission de nikol pashinian
l'aisne
iter qui avait pourtant soutenu l'accord
de cessez le feu dans le haut-karabagh
pourquoi ces changements de position je
pense que visiblement vous mais sur une
tendance longue c'est à dire qu'il faut
remonter déjà à 2018
l'arrivée au pouvoir de nikol pashinian
qui qui s'est fait également dans un
contexte de division de manifestations
et je pense qu'il ya également un bilan
aujourd'hui que l'arménie dresse un
bilan tout à fait catastrophique
dramatique de ce qu'a été la remise
depuis 25 ans est-ce que parallèlement
est devenu la terreur voiture hier qu'
il ya une décroissance démographique en
arménie une baisse de l'armement unis
l'activité diplomatique alors que de
l'autre côté l'azerbaïdjan a depuis sa
sa population croître 1 aujourd'hui il
faut rappeler c'est pas la moindre des
choses il ya trois azerbaïdjanais pour
un arménien elle sert mais de façon
comparable à renouer les liens avec la
turquie à la faveur notamment de
l'arrivée de red certaines y perdent ou
gagnent au pouvoir à ankara
elle a une politique tous azimuts
d'armement avec la russie avec la
turquie avec israël
et donc c'est une en fait une année
fondremand de la géopolitique de la
politique la diplomatie de la vision
stratégique de leur mini qui est
aujourd'hui sanctionner à ce que selon
vous le premier ministre arménien à a
commis des erreurs en termes de
politique extérieure pour l'arménie
de façon générale je pense qu'on ne
s'est pas occupé de ce conflit vous
savez qu'il existait depuis 1994 le
groupe de contact contact de minsk
coprésidé alors par la france la russie
et les etats unis ce groupe n'a jamais
été activé et qu'on aurait dû peut-être
d'ailleurs pensé à une solution
pacifique et durable avec un retrait
progressif de l'armée ni des territoires
ddt azerbaïdjan et en contrepartie de
reconnaissance de la souveraineté
arménienne haut-karabakh
la question c'est réglé hélas par par le
feu et le sang par le conflit et on peut
considérer que l'armée ne s'est pas bien
préparé
à ce conflit avec peut-être en
relâchement des liens des liens avec la
russie avec une absence de vision ou
vision géopolitique et puis volonté
d'être figée sur les déposer ses 25 ans
et dernière question rapidement un
changement de pouvoir comme demandé par
l'opposition pour est il relancé le
conflit contre l'azerbaïdjan est ce que
c'est un risque qui existe à court terme
certainement pas
vous savez la court terme je pense que
l'arménie aujourd'hui panse ses plaies
elle à sa tante de de douleur elle doit
accueillir plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés venus du
haut-karabakh sur son territoire qui ont
fui les territoires désormais sous la
sous la tutelle directe de bakou
aujourd'hui l'arménie en est plutôt à
arusha à se recomposer ce reconsidérer
plutôt qu'à une reprise du conflit ont
ensuite je pense que les les
protagonistes mal aux locaux la turquie
et puis la russie également n'y ont pas
intérêt du fait qu'ils ont ils sont
quand même arrivés à un conclura non
concluant un accord et qu'aujourd'hui
ils ont plutôt leur préoccupation
consiste plutôt à la mise en place de
l'accord merci beaucoup françois
constantine et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes l
géopolitologue premiers pas en libye
vers un gouvernement de transition le
premier ministre désigné abdelhamid el
beida a transmis hier au conseil
présidentiel la composition du cabinet
la liste des prétendants doit maintenant
être présenté au parlement au vue de son
approbation
cette future équipe ministérielle aura
pour mission d'unifier les institutions
libyenne est de mener la transition du
pays jusqu'aux élections générales
prévues le 24 décembre prochain on
écoute le premier ministre libyen nous
sommes sortis de la guerre des conflits
et des désaccords qui ont en fait
détruit ce pays est établi des divisions
et des scissions
nous sommes dans une phase dangereuse
nous avons pris en compte dans ce
gouvernement toutes ces considérations
un véritable gouvernement d'unité
nationale
nous avons trois vrais problèmes à
savoir la pandémie de coronavirus pour
laquelle nous allons créer une équipe de
crise propres le problème de
l'électricité est un autre problème qui
nécessite la formation de comités pour
unifier le peuple libyen à travers le
comité de réconciliation et en
coopération avec le conseil présidentiel
au nigeria 317 nouvelle adolescentes ont
été enlevées la nuit dernière dans le
nord du pays
leur pensionnat située dans l'état de
zamfara a été attaqué par une dizaine
d'hommes armés selon les autorités une
opération était lancé pour les secourir
ce rapt est le dernier d'une série
d'enlèvements dans le centre et le nord
ouest du pays par des groupes criminels
il ya une semaine et 42 autres élèves
avaient été enlevés dans un autre
établissement
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot